[Music]
halo 5 Guardians may have released last
year but developer 343 industries is
still hard at work maintaining the
shooter as of now the studio has updated
halo 5 with eight updates adding classic
multiplayer modes such as firefight and
big team battle but also larger
additions such as Forge the franchise's
long-running level creation tool and now
with Halo 5s ninth update on the horizon
Ford is making its way to PC welcome to
forge this changes a few things most
notably forges controls are deeper than
ever with mouse and keyboard inputs
allowing for precise edits and
mathematical changes you can click and
drag objects rotate walls and ceilings
and manually change object effects such
as the launching distance of man cannons
bringing the level creator to PC pose a
serious challenge for 343 not only did
the developer need to make the controls
more accessible for players accustomed
to console commands but also add the
death inherent to mouse and keyboard
input it's a paradox that 343 studio
head josh homme said was difficult to
solve
but once figured out led to much more
refinement in the complex mode you know
so one of the big goals for us by
bringing Forge to PC is just having the
precision of mouse and keyboard and you
know being able to very rapidly create
content and take advantage of all of the
features that are there within forge
just makes for an even better experience
building content Forge has always given
you a hammer and chisel now you have a
power saw to forge on PC also improves
the ease and speed with which you can
share your creations
Anvil's legacy features a forge library
of user created content complete with a
nuanced search filter and thumbnail
generator you can find a plethora of
creations ranging from Star Wars
inspired levels to giant foosball table
maps
lastly you can play through any of your
forged creations through Windows 10 that
is you can play Halo 5 custom
multiplayer games on PC with mouse and
keyboard controls
Slayer three four three has yet to
confirm whether the entirety of halo 5
will be ported to PC but as of now you
can take control of a Spartan with a
more precise control scheme playing
through yours and your friends maps with
your own weapon set skill counts and
time limits the mode SWAT feels
particularly at home here as you line up
headshots and quick bursts from your
battle rifle forges new home on PC is
part of a wider effort by 343 to keep
the blood pumping through Halo fives
veins I think for us when you look at
this this tool it is so powerful and our
hope is that we're going to be able to
have players come in that may have been
you know intimidated by Forge in the
past but now with some of the tutorials
that we have they can start to build
that capacity as creators and valenki
will also bring a free Halo app to
Windows 10 complete with trailers videos
and forum for Halo players to peruse so
although Halo 5 may have released in
2015 it's still very much alive at least
insofar as 343 keeps supporting it and
VLEs legacy is the next push in that
effort it adds more depth to forge it
adds sharing options to keep the
community connected it adds classic
shooter controls to the franchise's
customizable multiplayer matches Forge
has always been about fostering
creativity but now halo 5 players can
help maintain the pulse as well you're
going to see even more content come into
the mix and even more things for people
to be able to play with in the game so
I'm really excited to see you know what
people do with these tools and then
we're going to continue to support and
expand them over time
[Music]
you